it's exciting for me to be back on this
stage after all these years that's the
most thrilling thing what do you mean
back on this stage I thought Monday was
your first time here no no no I was on
that TV show Showtime at the Apollo yeah
many times in the 1980s I was on that
site I don't really unaware of ya know a
lot of crazy memories on this stage
there was this one time back in 1984 I
was just getting started I did stand-up
comedy and we actually have a clip it's
being a food baloney
which was baloney who came up with it
was the inventor like Jack baloney
baloney never trust the food that you
can fold up and put in your wallet
[Applause]
anymore had to hide my wallet cuz my
lady is always shopping I came back
but some and I came back the next year
and I came back very strong
[Applause]
okay I returned I didn't get discouraged
that's the key young people don't get
discouraged I returned in 1987 and I
killed it
what are you doing I can see us moving I
can see us moving you're not getting in
every time I talk
you see I came back I came back one more
time I came back one more time in 1989
and I tried to show my acting range
doing a one-man show it was critically
as great these famous people I does he
comes out Pacino getting mr. Pacino
pretty goodness to pacino here you are
Hey look who's coming in now
it's Angela Lansbury
[Music]
[Applause]
eight disembarking a half
you